[Musik]
jetzt live aus köln der presseclub mit
allen
hallo und herzlich willkommen tsum
presseclub an diesem sonntag schön dass
sie dabei sind fast auf den tag genau
drei monate ist es her dass russland die
ukraine überfallen hat und für präsident
putin ging es vor allem um ein ziel
nämlich dem westen und der nato
gegenüber stärke zu zeigen doch genau
das gegenteil hat der russische
präsident erreicht der krieg offenbart
deutliche schwächen seiner russischen
armee der westen ist geeint wie nie und
die nato bereitet sich auf zwei neue
mitgliedstaaten vor finnland und
schweden finnland war 80 jahre lang
militärisch neutral schweden sogar über
200 jahre lang also auch für diese
beiden länder steht jetzt ein
militärischer paradigmen und
seitenwänden wechsel an die vergangene
woche haben die beiden offiziell ihren
nato beitrittsgesuch eingereicht
ich begrüße ausdrücklich die anträge
finnlands und schwedens der nato
beizutreten sie sind unsere engsten
partner und ihre mitgliedschaft in der
nato wird unsere gemeinsame sicherheit
erhöhen finnland und schweden sie
könnten die nato stärker machen durch
eine beachtliche truppenstärke durch
modernes kampfgerät die
kräfteverhältnisse innerhalb europas
würden sich neu formieren die ostsee
würde zu einer art nato bin meer und die
direkte grenze zu russland deutlich
länger doch bislang droht die türkei mit
einem veto zu den nato beitritt
es ist inakzeptabel dass länder die
kandidaten für den beitritt sein wollen
terroristische organisationen
unterstützen die auf uns erzielen es ist
nicht nur politische unterstützung
beispielsweise liefert schweden waffen
an terroristische organisationen putin
hält einen beitritt für einen schweren
fehler und reagierte prompt erstellt den
finnen strom und gas ab außerdem will er
im westen russland seine truppen
verstärken der ausbau der militärischen
infrastruktur in diesem gebiet wird
offensichtlich eine reaktion erfordern
und wir werden bestimmt wie diese
reaktion ausfällt mit blick auf die
neuen bedrohungen
wäre mit dem beitritt der drohte hirntod
der nato wies frankreichs präsident
makro formuliert überwunden der beitritt
der beiden länder würde die allianz
stark verändert und genau das ist unser
thema heute im presseclub nato nord
erweiterung lebensversicherung gegen
putin und ich freue mich auf diese gäste
herzlich willkommen alexandra von nahmen
sie ist studioleiterin der deutschen
welle in brüssel ich begrüße anna sophie
schneider in der runde sie ist
redakteurin im auslandsressort beim
magazin der spiegel herzlich willkommen
auch christoph schiltz er ist eu und
nato korrespondent für die welt und ich
begrüße ganz herzlich verträgt pleitgen
er ist ziehen ja international
korrespondent beim us nachrichtensender
cnn mit sitz in london und berlin seien
sie alle ganz herzlich willkommen und
auch sie zu hause können sich an unserer
diskussion beteiligen über die sozialen
medien auf denen der presseclub präsent
ist sagen sie uns ihre meinung wir
wollen jetzt aber hier erstmal ein
steigen herr pleitgen vielleicht fange
ich mit ihnen an wir haben es ja gerade
gehört finnland und schweden sehr lange
militärisch neutral gewesen was ist
jetzt das besondere an der situation
dass die auch eine erkenntnis überhaupt
über den über bord werfen die schon so
lange gilt also ist wladimir putin und
seinen krieg in der ukraine das ist ganz
klar und die finden haben das auch
formuliert so und die und die schweden
auch die haben gesagt das ist jetzt
einfach so unsicher geworden in europa
mit diesem krieg in der ukraine ich
glaube sie halten den russischen
präsidenten auch für wesentlich
gefährlicher als viele leute ihn noch
vor ein paar jahren zum zum beispiel
empfunden haben und dass sie deswegen
gesagt haben jetzt ist für uns die zeit
der nato beizutreten was ich ganz
interessant finden an einem schweden und
finnland ist das sind ja keine
entscheidung die seine regierung einfach
mal trifft sondern dass die bevölkerung
da jetzt auch mehrheitlich dahinter
steht weil das war ja lange zeit auch
nicht der fall da war das hier für die
total okay neutral zu sein also da ist
schon ziemlich viel passiert man merkt
dass da ich glaube nicht dass es eine
angst ist wladimir putin und vor den
russen aber die glauben schon dass ihre
sicherheit jetzt einfach durch die nato
die jetzt stärker ist jetzt auch ein
ganz anderes selbstverständnis hat als
noch vor diesen krieg dass das einfach
jetzt besser gewährleistet ist gerade
finnland hat ja mit russland eine lande
lang landgrenze auch eine lange
wechselhafte geschichte an der stelle
und war sehr sehr lange darauf bedacht
den großen nachbarn nicht zu verärgern
was hat jetzt insbesondere in finnland
noch mal zu diesen paradigmenwechsel
geführt in finnland war es die angst vor
russland und dadurch dass der artikel 5
die sogenannte beistands klauseln jetzt
auch für finnland und schweden gilt wird
die schwelle für einen angriff natürlich
höher gelegt dass er hofft man sich
jedenfalls und insofern ist
das aus finnischer sicht und
schwedischer sich total rational
schweden hat hier aber nicht so eine
lange landgrenze mit wie vielen einbauen
will schweden auch mit rein schweden und
finnland waren immer sehr eng
sozusagen verbunden mit einander in
ihrer außenpolitik sie sind auch in
einem partnerschaftsabkommen und sie
sind beide die engsten partner in der
nato sie haben beide auch ein gastland
abkommen mit der nato das heißt schon
heute können nato truppen dort
stationiert werden und
schweden geht einfach in gleich kann
gleichklang mit finnland das ist aus
deren sicht rational und wenn es dem
land trifft dürfte es auch schweden
treffen insofern
gehen sie da im gleichschritt sie haben
ja gerade die partnerschaftlichen
absprachen genannt die jetzt schon
existieren könnte man ja auch sagen na
ja gut ist machen sie sowieso schon
warum ist das denn so ein gigantischer
schritt das sagen ja aber alle das ist
tatsächlich eine zeitenwende wie würde
sich denn ihrer meinung nach jetzt die
europäische sicherheitsarchitektur in
europa verändern wenn dieser beitritt
kommt wovon wir ja wahrscheinlich
ausgehen also zum einen muss man sagen
dass es natürlich ein großer gewinn für
die nato wäre wenn bei der länder der
nato beitreten
auch wenn es natürlich richtig ist dass
sie bereits schon jetzt die engsten
partner sind und zusammen mit der natur
arbeiten an sogar missionen teilnehmen
oder an übungen aber es würde sich viel
im ostseeraum verändern zum einen wenn
wir uns natürlich angucken was die
länder mitbringen das ist ja ein
bisschen den beitrag schon angeklungen
fähige gut ausgebildete armee die sich
auch natürlich auf die
landesverteidigung spezialisiert haben
dass es wichtig also würden sie auch zu
denjenigen gehören die auch für die
kollektive sicherheit innerhalb der nato
sorgen finden zum beispiel hat er hat
auch großartiger cyber abwehr
fähigkeiten auch sehr wichtig und
blick auf die gesamte situation im
ostseeraum muss man sagen dass wenn
schweden und finnland beitreten die nato
erst in der lage sein das baltikum zu
verteidigen verteidigen mit mit diesen
fähigkeiten und mit mit mit der
ausbreitung der nato im ostseeraum es
war ja nicht wirklich möglich deshalb
haben wir auch die baltischen staaten
sehr euphorisch reagiert das kann man
verstehen allein es gibt ein
nato-mitglied die türkei das gar nicht
euphorisch reagiert hat und sogar gesagt
hat also bislang kann ich denn überhaupt
nicht zustimmen finnland und schweden
dürfen nicht in die nato aufgenommen
werden frau schneider warum ist das so
welche gründe führt erdogan dann das ist
natürlich eine masche die kennt man von
erdogan der dreht international auf wenn
er in bedrängnis geraten ist und das ist
der fall schweden bietet ihm da jetzt
die gelegenheit weil schwedens politik
im schon länger ein dorn im auge ist die
unterstützung der kurdischen
organisationen und das gibt ihnen jetzt
die möglichkeit sich international als
starker mann zu inszenieren zu zeigen
dass ohne die türkei nichts geht und das
sendet signale also er hätte das auch
hinter verschlossener tür machen können
das macht er nicht er möchte dass das
ankommt in washington in brüssel aber
auch bei seinen eigenen wlan weil
erdogan redet immer auch nach innen der
ist im wahlkampfmodus spätestens im
nächsten jahr werden
präsidentschaftswahlen seien in der
türkei und sein sieg ist alles andere
als sicher also er versucht da bei den
eigenen wählerinnen zu punkten er
verquickt ja jetzt zwei themen die gar
nichts miteinander zu tun haben also der
nato beitritt und sein thema was er mit
den den kurden hat sag ich jetzt mal so
die pkk vielleicht auch für unsere
zuschauer noch mal die pkk ist eine
organisation die in weiten teilen
europas als verbotene organisation gilt
aber nicht in schweden und finnland und
jetzt versucht erdogan
da durch die hintertür druck aufzubauen
in einer ganz anderen frage die
eigentlich mit der nato mitgliedschaft
nichts zu tun hatten das stimmt es geht
vor allen dingen auch um die
unterstützung der gpg in nordsyrien da
hat finnland
versprochen zu unterstützen dann geht es
zum beispiel um wasserprojekte und c
erdogan ist es einfach
mit dem thema kurden kann man in der
türkei immer punkten und das musste
jetzt einfach aus wpg ist die kurdische
organisation genau das ist seriös die
auch von den usa übrigens
unterschiedlichste genau die usa und aus
schweden sehen einen partner in der epg
und die türkei sieht darin den
verlängerten arm der verbotenen
kurdischen arbeiterpartei pkk
bleibt gemeint sie denn dass erdogan mit
diesem ich sah man kann ja auch sagen es
ein bisschen balsam also ich helfe euch
bei finnland und schweden und dann kann
ich meinen kunden thema bearbeiten wie
wie glauben sie wird das weitergehen die
ich glaube dass die am ende nicht
einknicken würde aber einlenken würde
ich glaube am ende wird das so
darstellen dass auf jeden fall finnland
und schweden in die nato reinkommen und
ich glaube dass der erdung an der hat ja
auch ein paar andere sachen noch
durchblicken lassen also es ist ja schon
so ein bisschen alles auch mit der nato
so ein bisschen verquickt war einerseits
hat er natürlich ein problem wir gesagt
dann mit finnland schweden aber die
türken haben ja schon durchblicken
lassen dass er sehr gerne moderne waffen
kriegen würden an diese bislang nicht
reinkommen die türken war natürlich
extrem verärgert aus dem f 35 programm
von den usa rausgekegelt wurden ein
weise sicher kampf die kampfflieger der
modernste kampfflieger der welt und
eigentlich den den gegen die
bundesregierung jetzt auch anschaffen
will weil das so als als der standard
jetzt demnächst gilt auch radar
abweisend kann man nicht sehen weil die
türken sich von den russen
flugabwehrrakete gekauft haben die es
400 und dass er da hat die daten an die
usa gesagt das geht nicht weil die s 400
könnte vielleicht die schwächen von der
f 35 aus und haben die türken aus dem
programm heraus genommen so die türken
wollen aber gerne militärisches modernes
gerät haben und wir haben auch schon
durchblicken lassen dass das auch ein
teil ist von ihrer haltung dass darüber
auch extrem sauer sind und da bedarf es
dann vielleicht irgendwann
gespräch zwischen herrn erdogan und
herren beiden um das dann wieder in die
bahn zu lenken aber ich denke das wird
passieren ich glaube die naht die die
türkei hätte mit einem veto des ganzen
unheimlich viel zu verlieren dann als
unzuverlässig zu gelten die türkei ist
ja in den letzten jahren eigentlich
eines der wichtigsten länder in der nato
gewesen wenn man sich anguckt wo die
konflikte stattgefunden haben in syrien
im irak der konflikt der stent auch wenn
man sie mit mit mit dem iran auch das
ist ja auch eine sache die langfristig
wichtig ist das wäre für die türkei wäre
es ein riesenproblem denn sich quer
stellen würde für die natürlich auch und
deswegen glaube ich dass wird dass wir
uns im endeffekt dass das das glaube ich
auch spätestens zum nato gipfel ende
juni wird sich das ändern und wird die
türkei
sozusagen zugeständnisse machen und ich
gehe auch davon aus dass bis ende des
jahres finnland und schweden in der nato
sein werden ich glaube es geht doch auch
um andere themen über die gar nicht so
geredet wird zum beispiel über die
beitrittsverhandlungen die laufen seit
1999 die eu-beitrittsverhandlungen der
türkei und jetzt sieht erdogan auf
einmal dort sollen zwei länder innerhalb
von monaten in die nato hinein kommen ja
und er hat im märz hat er innerhalb von
neun tagen hat er vier eu-staatschefs
gesprochen und hat dort jeweils den
beitritt zum thema gemacht das ärgert
die türken ungemein dass sie dort nicht
weiterkommen und seit 20 jahren quasi
über 20 jahren beitrittsverhandlungen
führen und ich habe weitere verhandlung
wie gesagt es geht jetzt auch um zwei
verschiedene und wenn dieser nach unten
ja vielleicht einfach mal also dass das
das motiv bündel von erdogan ist
einerseits die kurdenfrage die ihn immer
auch innenpolitisch umtreibt die waffen
frage er will moderne amerikanische
waffen kaufen und er sieht dass man sehr
schnell in die nato reinkommen kann aber
er sehr lange auf die eu warten muss
also drei themen die nur mittelbar jetzt
mit der frage zu tun haben sollen
finnland und schweden in die nato
eintreten als sachfremde diskussion aber
es ist stellen es ist ja schon ein
gewisser weise
passt das ein bisschen zusammen weil er
einfach schon auch ich würde nicht sagen
misstrauen aber eine gewisse wut glaube
ich auf den westen hat nämlich so gut
auch er ist ja auch eigentlich teil des
westens aber europa und den usa und das
zieht sich die frau schneider gesagt hat
auch über die letzten jahre hinweg also
es war ja auch so dass er mit den
amerikanern sehr unzufrieden war was was
dieser ganze syrien einsatz ein anging
war hat er gesagt ihr könnt gegen den
islamischen staat kämpfen das war auch
in der türkei nicht so beliebt
gingen die es so in der art vorzugehen
weil es ja natürlich auch sehr viele
leute gab die gegen assad sehr stark
waren und erdogan ja auch sehr stark
gegen assad war aber er hat ihnen gesagt
ihr könnt das auf gar keinen fall mit
den kurden als eure bodentruppen das
ging dann irgendwann nicht mehr anders
weil jan usa haben ja versucht selbst
kämpfer auszubilden die sind alle
gekidnappt worden nach ein paar stunden
das hat er nicht funktioniert und
irgendwann hat der ist halt qurbani
überfallen und dann war klar man muss
einfach damit sie überleben muss man die
unterstützen das hat aber enorm große
probleme mit dem erdogan
ausgelöst und natürlich auch der
putschversuch wo er weiter der westen
ist nicht auf meiner seite putin ist auf
seiner seite dann kamen das
techtelmechtel mit wladimir putin wo man
sich schon gedanken gemacht hat ob er
überhaupt noch in der allianz bleiben
will der erdung an als es ist ich glaube
der hat schon eine sehr große wut auch
gegenüber vielen westlichen staaten und
und machte mit luft
gerade weil vielleicht mehr putin sind
die hat man kann ich komme auf jeden
fall jetzt zu nutzen und erdogan zurück
also syrien ich hoffe der zuschauer
kommt noch folgen ich sag mal so also im
wesentlichen heißt es ja ich versuche es
noch mal zu resümieren erdogan möchte
nicht dass irgendwo auf der welt wurden
unterstützt werden die ig in nordsyrien
ist eine kurdische organisation die von
den amerikanern unter anderem
unterstützt wird um gegen den
islamischen staat zu kämpfen deshalb ist
es also ein grundthema und dazu dann
erst deine putin einmal einen haken und
sagen man kann sich natürlich auch die
frage stellen inwieweit diese vorbehalte
aus der türkei jetzt vielleicht auch als
zeichen an putin zu verstehen sind weil
das verhältnis zwischen erdogan und
putin ist nicht einfach die türkei ist
abhängiger als die meisten westlichen
länder vom wohlwollen putins und
er hat sich da zuletzt als vermittler
inszeniert und seine vorbehalte könnten
jetzt natürlich auch so ein bisschen
versöhnungssignale an putin sein weil
gerade auch die türkischen drohen eine
große rolle spielen in der ukraine und
ja zumindest genau dazu das möchte ich
auch gern den zuschauern noch mal kurz
erklären also erdogan hat an der stelle
tatsächlich einerseits kann man positiv
sagen eine vermittlerrolle andere würden
sagen eine zwiespältige rolle erkauft
luftabwehrsysteme aus russland aber er
gibt seine drohnen an die ukraine mit
denen jetzt die ukrainische truppen auch
sich sehr gut verteidigen können gucken
wir mal auf diese zwiespältige rolle und
in dem zusammenhang möchte ich gerne
zwei fragen von twitter einbinden die
sich beide auf eigentlich dasselbe thema
beziehen es gibt ja eben solche
organisationen wie die nato durch
einstimmigkeitsprinzip können die
lahmgelegt werden braucht es nicht ein
neues prinzip beziehungsweise einen
schritt weiter gedacht könnte man sogar
ein nato mitgliedsstaat aus diesem
bündnis zwingen auszutreten na also
jetzt in dem fall wenn sich die türkei
da lange länger sperren würde
wie blicken sie wie blicken sie sich
heute noch verlassen bevor wir das
beantworten auch sagen dass tatsächlich
aus diesen vielen hier genannten gründen
ist die türkei ein sehr schwieriger
bündnispartner für die nato seit dem
militärputsch versuch 2016 vor allem und
wir hören ja auch am nato hauptquartier
das ist viele kleinere entscheidungen
gibt wo die türkei sagt wir blockieren
ein bisschen dann einigen sie sich doch
insofern ist dass jedem klar dass die
türkei ein schwieriger partner ist aber
man braucht die türkei aufgrund deren
bedeutung in bündnissen und das haben
wir jetzt auch in der ukraine krise im
krieg gesehen dass zum beispiel als
präsident lynskey erdogan angerufen hat
und gesagt hat die der zugang zum
schwarzen meer sollte für russische
blockiert werden dann ist es dann direkt
am nächsten tag erfolgt und mit der
türkei ist die nato natürlich auch
stärker insofern würde ich sagen dass
das das motiv ist warum man sagt wir
wollen sie dann haben wir wollen auch
etwas anbieten damit sie am ende
zustimmen dass finnland und schweden
neue mitglieder in der nato werden
glauben sie dass man das
einstimmigkeitsprinzip jetzt mal
überdenken müsste oder dann überhaupt
nicht das schützt vor allem die
kleineren staaten und es hat ja auch
niemals bisher eine diskussion seitens
der türkei gegeben am ende hat sie immer
mit gestimmt hat immer ärger gemacht das
ist sozusagen eingepreist in der nato
jetzt am mittwoch sind sie ein wenig
überrumpelt worden da hatte man sich
schon erhofft dass sie keine probleme
machen werden deswegen war auch nachdem
das gesuch morgens eingegangen war
sofort am frühen morgen noch ein nato
rat das und da waren sie überrascht aber
die stimmung so wie weit ich das höre
ist das werden wir schon hinkriegen und
so war es eigentlich immer mit ihnen
denken sie an die schwierigkeiten mit
deutschland denken sie an die
schwierigkeiten mit den niederlanden
hat seine eigene agenda und wie frau von
namen schon gesagt hat das land ist sehr
wichtig hat die zweitgrößte armee hat in
libyen im sinne des westens agiert
stellt basel zur verfügung im kampf
gegen den islamischen staat
nimmt flüchtlinge in hohem maße auf das
eines der wenigen länder ist in
afghanistan noch agieren genau also
selbst wenn man es könnte sollte man es
auf keinen fall tun und das ausschließen
dass wäre wäre völlig kontraproduktiv
verhältnis zwischen dem erdogan und dem
putin auch extrem abgekühlt ist also ich
meine nicht ich glaube der erdogan hatte
mal eine phase wo er geglaubt hat dass
er sich vielleicht auf den putin ein
bisschen verlassen kann und das ist dann
möglicherweise auch eine engere
kooperation auch in militärfragen gehen
kann man die türkei natürlich schon
gemerkt hat dass der westen oder west
ihr staaten dem viele sachen nicht
verkaufen wollen wie zum beispiel auch
diese diese diese patriot-raketen die er
haben wollte im vor die dsw 100 gekostet
aber ich glaube der erdogan hat gerade
in syrien auch gemerkt dass er ein ums
andere mal von putin hintergangen wurde
und und teilweise auch ganz ganz
schlecht dastand das gab mir dann die
idee
putin hatte den laster unterstützt und
dessen truppen und der handel hat die
rebellen auf der anderen seite gehabt
und es wird so oft vorgekommen dass die
es eigentlich untereinander aufgeteilt
haben und er hasst hatten trotzdem vor
marschiert ist mit starker
luftunterstützung der russen und ich
glaube das war für den putin teilweise
echt schwer das ganze zu schlucken und
ich glaube dass diese bayraktar thronen
wir sind ja nicht von ungefähr auf
einmal so weit gehen dass es die drohne
nahe an die ukraine liefert weil die
ukraine liefert und die einfach also das
ist einer der gründe warum kiew jetzt
nicht von den russen besetzt ist intakt
ar.drone ich war in butter gewesen da
ist eine ganz berühmte straße gewesen wo
ein riesiger konvoi von russischen
panzern lag die alle komplett zerstört
worden und haben uns die leute nur
gesagt da kam auf einmal die drohnen
haben die einfach einen nach dem anderen
und angeschossen und radiosender
mittlerweile radio bayraktar sogar das
war es nämlich richtig
er hat sie ganz am anfang des krieges
geliefert werden in deutschland noch
herum geguckt wird und diskutiert wird
ist er sofort gekommen das war
wahrscheinlich wäre die ukraine schon am
boden wänden in der türke nicht geholfen
machen wir vielleicht an der stelle kurz
mal einen punkt also sie sagen alle am
tisch irgendwie wird das türkische veto
wahrscheinlich durch zugeständnisse
verhandlungen ähnliches beseitigt werden
finnland und schweden werden der nato
beitreten können und wenn es alles gut
läuft sogar schon bis zum jahresende
sie haben es gerade angesprochen das
verhältnis erdogan und putin hat sich
ein bisschen abgekühlt also das
verhältnis zu putin hat sich glaube ich
bei vielen staatenlenkern abgekühlt in
den letzten drei monaten aber wie wird
denn putin jetzt darauf reagieren wenn
tatsächlich diesen ort erweiterung kommt
also schweden und finnland eintreten es
gibt menschen die sagen das ist jetzt
genau der richtige zeitpunkt und es gibt
menschen die sagen das ist eine unnötige
provokation weil es gibt ja sowieso
schon diese zusammenarbeit werden muss
das jetzt noch sein was meinen sie ja
ich verstehe die frage
nicht so ganz sicher gestellt wird weil
wenn finnland und schweden und vor allem
finnland jetzt sagt dass sie sich
bedroht fühlen dass sich das gesamte die
gesamte sicherheitsarchitektur dort
verändert hat dann bedeutet das
natürlich dass sie jetzt den prozess
einleiten wollen weil es einen grund
gibt und dass es russlands krieg gegen
die ukraine da hat sich der dann
bedrohungsszenario oder so wie sie ist
das wie sie das empfinden verändert und
dass wir deswegen wollen sie mitglied in
der nato sein also ist der zeitpunkt
richtig jetzt zu glauben dass man
dadurch putin provozieren könnte was ist
die alternative gar nichts zu tun und
überhaupt nicht diese option in erwägung
ziehen wir haben schon gesagt gesehen
dass natürlich der kreml gedroht hat die
russen haben ihre lieferungen
stromlieferungen nach finnland gestoppt
jetzt wird auch kein gas geliefert ob
alles kein so großes problem für
finnland aber ich glaube die
entscheidung ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
trotzdem richtig weil man natürlich auch
putin zeigen muss das ist die ursache
der krieg in der ukraine
und das ist die konsequenzen wir haben
ja gerade in dem kleinen einspieler
gehört von putin es wird offensichtlich
eine reaktion erfordern wann und wie die
kommt ist natürlich putin überlassen was
erwarten sie schneider also ich gehe
damit den beiden staaten und in schweden
und sind dann dass man relativ gelassen
beide staaten sind gut vorbereitet und
es wird mit weiteren provokationen
gerechnet und das kann jetzt zum einen
können dass cyber angriffe seien
zwischenfälle an der grenze oder auch
verletzungen des luftraums zum beispiel
und man ist darauf vorbereitet
eben ein bisschen gehört der gasstopp
ist zum beispiel versehen dann kein
problem ist es kein grund zur panik man
war auch darauf vorbereitet und ist
jetzt auch gelassen was da kommt aber es
gibt ja jetzt schon offensichtlich eine
offensichtliche reaktion dass die
westlichen militäraktivitäten russlands
verstärkt werden sollen also an der in
der nordwestlichen grenze
was könnte putin davor haben wie
bedrohen
kann er da nicht wirklich nicht
realistischer weise machen also zunächst
einmal ganz schön viele von seiner
militärischen der von seinen
gerätschaften schon verloren in der
ukraine da ist schon relativ viel die
frage ist was der dafür ein aufmaß
starten könnte er hat sicherlich noch
viele panzer aber wenn man sich anschaut
die die finnen die die sind ja auch so
was auch vorbereitet die finden die sind
ja schon immer die nachbarn der russen
gewesen da gab es ja schon gegenseitig
invasion und und die sind auf sowas
eingestellt und die haben ein
hochmodernes militär und die könnten
sowas auch ganz schnell ab wären also
ich glaube dass ich glaube nicht dass
die russen das auch versuchen würden
weil ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen
dass da jetzt unbedingt eine zweite
front aufmachen will jetzt noch ein
krieg mit der nato anfang das wäre dass
wir gut ich mein mann hat ja auch vor
dass die ukraine schon verrückt ist aber
dass wir ja dann zumal sie selbst wollen
die fina in die nato weil sie sagen mit
unseren fünf millionen und sechs
millionen menschen könnten wir wenn
nicht viel ausrichten sollte russland
tatsächlich besuchen und zu attackieren
und deswegen ist es besser wir tun uns
besser geschützt weil wir unsere partner
in der nato haben wo wir wissen dass es
da die kollektive sicherheit gibt es
heißt dass uns unsere partner zu hilfe
kommen jetzt ist es ja so dass diese
militärische stützpunkte russlands an
der westgrenze verstärkt werden und wir
haben wahrscheinlich noch bis zum
jahresende schweden und finnland nicht
offiziell im bündnis drin was könnte in
dieser zeit passieren oder wie muss man
die beiden länder möglicherweise auch
schützen in der zeit ich möchte noch
einmal auf die vorherige frage zu
sprechen die atomare bedrohung
finnlands und schwedens ist heute
eigentlich schon da die russen haben auf
dieser in dieser enklave kaliningrad die
sich zwischen polen und litauen befindet
haben sie schon iskender im boden
raketen stationiert ja liebe finden sich
auf lastwagen und die kann man relativ
mobil
transportieren und die sind nur klar
gestützt
bestückbar und die haben eine reichweite
von ungefähr 500 kilometern das heißt
die könnten heute schon berlin erreichen
die könnten heute schon kopenhagen
erreichen und sie könnten heute schon
warschau erreichen und viel mehr geht
eigentlich gar nicht als diese atomare
bedrohung die aber schon lange da ist
und um auf ihre andere frage zu sprechen
zu kommen da wird das cyber angriffe
geben da wir dass das
informationskampagnen hetzkampagnen
geben
und ich schließe nicht aus dass man auch
mal alleine eine kurzstreckenrakete
vielleicht im extremsten fall in
irgendeinem finnischen see fliegen
lassen ja um einfach zu die
stabilisieren um panik auszulösen aber
nicht um menschen
zu
sozusagen zu töten ja aber die
sicherheitsgarantien seitens der usa
sind ja jetzt da und die werden auch
funktionieren also die usa haben im
wesentlichen beschrieben das bis zu dem
offiziellen nato beitritt man sich sehr
eng mit finnland und schweden
abstimmungen würde also etwas was quasi
klingt wie ein beistandsverpflichtung
wie wie im nato sind
vielleicht noch die frage an sie herr
bleibt also wenn ich das richtig
wahrgenommen habe war ja die erste
russische reaktion große empörung und
wie kann es sein und dann hieß es ein
paar tage später ja aber so lange da
jetzt keine neuen nato stützpunkte in
schweden und finnland errichtet werden
ist es ja alles gar nicht so schlimm
weil genau die partnerschaft gibt es ja
sowieso ist also wie schätzen sie das
ich glaube dass ich glaub das team putin
nicht nur innerlich sondern auch
äußerlich scheint daher sehr wütend ist
weil es ist ja alles das was er geglaubt
hat was er erreichen könnte alles nicht
passiert also dass er die nato schwächen
kann ist ja nicht passiert ist stärker
als als seit langem war und kriegt jetzt
auch neue mitglieder es gab da herrscht
eine extreme wut
und andererseits versucht man das
natürlich klein zu reden weil ich glaub
die russen wissen auch dass sie
eigentlich realistischerweise da nicht
wirklich viel daran ändern können und
dass sie eigentlich auch da dann nicht
so viel machen können aus der
cyberangriffe da sind die wir finden ja
auch sehr sehr gut darin sowas
abzuwehren und die suchen ich weiß was
ich glaube dass die russen jetzt einfach
auch die richtige sprache suchen bei
einerseits
wollen sie schon ihre wut ausdrücken und
andererseits wollen sie sagen ja
eigentlich brauchen wir euch auch gerne
soll es eigentlich egal aber hat er dann
gesagt die sicherheitslage ändert sich
überhaupt gar nicht das passt natürlich
wieder nicht zusammen damit dass man
direkt das gas in den strom abdreht wenn
man dann so sauer ist also ich glaube
die ringender selbst noch so ein
bisschen um die richtige sprache aber
aber realistischerweise wissen die
glaube ich auch dass man da relativ
wenig daran ändern kann also die wissen
dass sie eine harte konfrontation jetzt
mit der nato haben werden dass die nato
jetzt extrem moment sehr sehr
geschlossen ist und und das ist einfach
eine realität mit der die russen jetzt
jetzt leben und die werden dass ich
glaube schon dass die schon
möglicherweise dann mehr atomraketen an
diese gegend vielleicht bringen können
lukaschenko hat ja auch schon in weißer
schrift die russen sind ja auch schon
verlauten dass er seine abneigung gegen
atomwaffen auf seinem territorium jetzt
auch nicht mehr da ist aber dass das ist
dann eigentlich
erneuter kalter krieg der dann denn wir
werden recht schnell jetzt eine antwort
bekommen weil die nato will ja jetzt ein
neues sicherheitskonzept
beschließen spätestens bis zum herbst da
wird der madrider gipfel ende juni eine
wichtige rolle spielen aber man will
sich neu aufstellen angesichts der
bedrohung an der sogenannten ostflanke
und es werden deutlich deutlich mehr
soldaten dorthin kommen auch deutlich
mehr waffen schwere waffen und wie schon
gesagt haben putin hat im grunde das
gegenteil dessen erreicht was er
erreichen wollte und da wird schweden
natürlich in diesem neuen konzept der
sogenannten verstärkten vorne präsenz
wie das in der nato genannt wird werden
schweden und finnland natürlich auch
eine rolle spielen wir werden sehr
schnell sehen und putin wird vor allem
sehr schnell sehen wie schweden und
finnland im zukünftigen
sicherheitskonzept der nato eingebunden
und glauben sie das dann tatsächlich
auch us stützpunkte in finnland und
schweden nato stützpunkte in finnland
und schweden geben könnte oder atom
gattung glaube ich nicht weil diese
forderung hatte vor einiger zeit ja mal
kaczynski in der welt am sonntag polen
starker mann in der welt am sonntag
gestellt und ich habe häufiger bei der
nato nachgefragt darüber wird nicht
diskutiert also atomwaffen wird es nicht
geben auch nicht in schweden und
finnland aber die russen werden auch
ihre aktivitäten in der arktis noch
weiter verstärken und deswegen macht es
sinn dort auch möglicherweise sogar bis
zu 3000 4000 soldaten also in brigade
stärke zu stationären das wir bekommen
einfach auch um ein kohärentes konzept
zu haben ja das dann von bulgarien bis
oben hoch nach schweden reicht ja
also gehen wir mal davon aus finnland
und schweden werden bis jahresende
beitreten die türkischen sorgen werden
ausgeräumt es gibt eine neue strategie
die sie ja jetzt gerade schon so ein
bisschen beschrieben haben vielleicht
gehen wir zurück auf den blick auf die
ukraine es gibt ja menschen die sagen
jetzt erst recht muss man auch der
ukraine wieder diese option eröffnung
nato-mitgliedschaft dass ich jetzt nicht
bei der eu sondern bei der nato
mitgliedschaft wolfgang ischinger der
ehemalige vorsitzende der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz hat das jetzt
gerade nochmal gesagt wie blicken sie
darauf frau schneider glauben sie dass
mehrere überhaupt ein realistisches
vorhaben in diesen zeiten die ukraine
ist mitten im krieg
ist ja ist es zumindest etwas das man
diskutieren sollte weil die nato
erweiterung bringt der ukraine erst mal
gar nichts also der ukraine ist damit
nicht geholfen wenn schweden und
finnland in der nato beitragen beitreten
und entsprechend muss man schon schauen
wie man dem land weiter helfen kann und
welche optionen es gibt für eine zukunft
der ukraine es ist ja so dass das was
die ukraine eigen ich bekommen möchte
nämlich sicherheitsgarantien um nicht
noch mal oder nicht noch weiter von
russland militärisch bedrängt zu werden
das ist etwas was ja eigentlich nur ein
bündnis wie die nato oder starke länder
wie die amerikaner oder wer auch immer
abgeben können wie stehen sie dazu also
herr china sagt jetzt die ukraine auch
in die nato muss man zumindest darüber
diskutieren man kann darüber diskutieren
das wäre natürlich wahrscheinlich der
einzige weg um die ukraine vor künftigen
angriffen seitens russlands zu schützen
aber ich kann mir im moment nicht
vorstellen dass auch die ukrainische
regierung und präsident seelands kehrt
dafür plädieren könnten denn das würde
ja bedeuten im prinzip dass man erst mal
einen waffenstillstand hat das heißt
dann die einzige möglichkeit ist
vermutlich dann doch einige gebiete
abzugeben und dann zu sagen wir wollen
die nicht zurückholen der teil der
ukraine der dann geblieben ist könnte
dann mit der nato verhandeln aber wollen
dass die menschen in der ukraine könnte
als lenski das innenpolitisch überleben
das kann ich mir im moment nicht
vorstellen weil er gerade jetzt an
diesem wochenende hat er noch einmal
dafür plädiert dass die ukraine alle
gebiete zurück haben möchte natürlich
auch die krim
das heißt da kommen wir wieder direkt in
die frage wie geht es eigentlich mit dem
ukraine krieg welche welche optionen
gibt es dann wie kanzler weiter gehen
herr pleitgen wie blicken sie darauf und
sich durch die ukraine weiter kämpfen
werden und ich glaube zurzeit sieht es
für die ukraine jetzt auch nicht so
schlecht aus wie man muss ja
zurückblicken und gucken was die leute
am anfang von krieg gedacht haben also
dass das in vier tagen vorbei ist dass
sie nach kiew einmal schön was die
russen auch gedacht haben ich würde man
nach ihr verzehren dass er sich auch
gesehen da sind die russen der
teilweisen geschützten konvois seien
gefallen weil die gesagt dass wir ein
zuckerschlecken das wird total einfach
und die großen namen hier verloren die
russen heimische zum zweiten mal in
haake verloren gehen am anfang einen
marschierten haben sie es wieder
versucht im don was gewinn sind bisschen
an territorium dass das könnte die
ukraine die die halten das schon mehr
auf als die meisten leute denken aber
die russen haben einfach einen
geschützten im moment so viel mehr als
die ukraine und die konzentrieren sich
auch auf den don was aber ansonsten
sieht so die ukraine wesentlich besser
aus als gedacht haben und die usa jetzt
sie haben jetzt die das paket
verabschiedet der beiden das gerade
unterzeichnen für 40 milliarden dollar
von 20 milliarden für neue waffen sind
das könnte für die russen schon
schwierig werden wird
ich teile diese recht optimistische
sicht nicht er stimmt kiew konnte nicht
eingenommen werden aktiv konnte auch
nicht
eingenommen werden obwohl charkiw glaube
ich jetzt gerade für die
auseinandersetzung im don was nicht so
wichtig ist aber
und darauf weisen zum beispiel die
militärexperten der theresianischen
militärakademie in wien hängen es
gelingt schon jetzt an den flügeln des
kessels der jetzt im don was gebildet
wird dass die russen immer mehr
einsickern ja und es
sind am ende drei fragen glaube ich die
entscheidend sind wie viel kann die
erste frage ist wie viel kann putin noch
an soldaten nach schießen wenn ich das
so sagen darf ja bisher hatte er den
krieg noch nicht erklärt das heißt alle
freiwilligen und oder wehrpflichtigen
können bisher noch nicht eingesetzt
werden offiziell die zweite frage wird
sein und die wird mindestens genauso
wichtig sein wie lange wir der westen
noch waffen liefern ja eher stoltenberg
hat vor zwei wochen gesagt erstens der
west muss viel mehr liefern der westen
muss viel schneller liefern und er muss
sehr lange liefern ja also und wenn ich
dieses gehöre in deutschland sehe die
diskussionen die herr scholz dort wird
der deutsche bundeskanzler dann kann
mich nicht kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
dass die waffen sehr schnell kommen
werden und war auch nicht lange vor
allem nicht lange und das wird nämlich
so eine sache sein wie lange wird der
westen noch in der lage seien
waffen zu liefern weil irgendwann wird
der westen sagen wir brauchen die waffen
für uns wir müssen ja auch unsere nato
verpflichtungen erfüllen und das wieder
ein großes problem werden und die dritte
frage ist die eigentlich nie im westen
diskutiert wird wie viel kommt
eigentlich an von den waffen wir reden
da immer wir müssen waffen schicken
waffen schicken nachjagt da sind sie
gekommen die waffen deswegen haben die
russen dort auch nicht gewinnen können
aber die die experten aus der
militärakademie in wien sagen es komme
zum beispiel ganz ganz wenige und vor
allem keine schweren waffen in den don
bass weil die transportwege immer
unterbrochen werden die die russen haben
eine ganz wichtige eisenbahnbrücke bei
und deshalb zerstört deswegen kommt kein
treibstoff mehr und auch keine waffen
mehr von rumänien rein kommen einfach
nicht mehr rein und von oben da werden
immer mehr trafostationen und umschalt
stationen die wichtig sind für die
sogenannten elektroloks die haben fast
nur elektroloks dort
werden dort gezielt angegriffen und die
können weder waffen noch lebensmittel
noch was ganz wichtig ist treibstoff in
dem maße transportieren wie es nötig
wäre und ich glaube deshalb
wenn ich mich zwar etwas
pessimistische prognose hinreißen lassen
darf dass putin noch lange nicht
verloren hat dass putin am ende auch
diesen krieg gewinnen wird und zwar in
dem sinne dass er deutlich mehr
land besitzen wird als vor diesem krieg
ja also ich glaube dass er chancen hat
den don bass und auch die süd ukraine
einzunehmen leider gottes
und die zeit spielt mit ihm ich glaube
auch wenn ich das als letztes noch sagen
darf ich glaube auch dass im westen im
laufe des herbstes spätestens eine
gewisse kriegsmüdigkeit eintreten wird
da wird es für die politischen akteure
im westen immer schwerer sein zu sagen
warum schicken wir da immer noch geld
ist und der seelen ski will immer noch
neues und er ist nie zufrieden natürlich
kann er nicht zufrieden sein das kann
man ihnen nicht vorwerfen aber
dass bei den amerikanern die 40
milliarden die jetzt genehmigt wurden da
gab es auch schon wochen im kongress wie
werden sich die italiener verhalten
dagegen bei den waffenlieferungen und
das wird sukzessive dieser konsens und
diese ukraine euphorie wenn ich das mal
so sagen darf die wird so fürchte ich
etwas bröckeln und deswegen
bin ich etwas pessimistischer als es
sich vielleicht im moment immer ins
spiel man hört das wird vermutlich so
sein je länger der krieg andauert aber
auf der anderen seite gibt es auch
probleme und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass putin so ewig
weitermachen kann denn die militärische
komponente ist nur eine komponente hinzu
kommt kommen die sanktionen verhängt
wurden und die werden auch dem
russischen militär wehtun das wird sich
zeigen nicht jetzt sofort natürlich kann
man jetzt noch auch für normale menschen
die sehen das vielleicht auch noch nicht
in moskau dass es eben sanktionen gibt
noch kann man sachen kaufen noch könnten
produkte hergestellt werden aber das
witzig vermutlich im laufe der nächsten
monate und des nächsten jahres ändern
und deswegen wird putin auch überlegen
müssen was ist mir wichtig wie weit kann
ich die front halten es wird der krieg
wird noch brutale werden mit sicherheit
dadurch dass wussten noch mehr ihre alte
artillerie einsetzten werden aber
irgendwann wird putin auch sagen müssen
ok
waffenstillstand irgend ein abkommen das
sichern was wir bisher erarbeitet haben
und dann konsolidieren wenn es dennoch
möglich ist weil ich glaube dass wir
momentan nicht einschätzen können
wirklich was die sanktionen am ende zu
russland bedeutet wir sind fast am ende
der sendung ankommt ich möchte aber
einmal noch spiegeln was sie gerade
gesagt haben herr schild also sie sagen
leider steht zu befürchten dass russland
dauerhaft den dollars und die süd
ukraine inklusive der krim besetzen wird
und halten wird sehen sie das auch so
ich überhaupt nicht so ich glaube dass
die russen langfristig zurückgedrängt
werden vor allem in südindien jetzt
schon große probleme in herzen weil es
nämlich dort auch so ist das eine sache
über die wir auch zu wenig reden dass
die bevölkerung josten da nicht haben
will und das ist in mariupol so das ist
in hessen so dass es vielleicht ein don
was ein bisschen weniger weil das pro
russische leute sind aber insgesamt
glaube ich die leute wollen die gar
nicht haben die werden schwierigkeiten
haben sich schon allein deswegen dazu
halten ihr müsst ihr jetzt schon
irgendwie leute verprügeln dass sie
nicht jeden tag auf die straße gehen und
was man nicht vergessen darf ist dass
die haltung von der bundesregierung mit
etwas zögerlichen haltung überwachen die
ist halt anderswo nicht so die ist in
den usa ist das ein ganz ganz anderes
und die usa haben wir schon gezeigt dass
sie sehr lange in der lage sind so ein
konflikt weiter zu betreiben denn wenn
es sein muss sie haben das geld dafür
die haben wir das geld in der
wirtschaftskrise auch auf weiterhin
dafür die haben nach afghanistan die
lange zeit weiter gemacht auch als das
öffentlich schon gar nicht mehr so
richtig dass er aber die frage ist ob
der öffentliche konsens dafür da ist und
wir es ja das ist ja nicht mal dass ich
da sind wir schon fast immer bei
afghanistan ja auch gedacht dass der
möglicherweise denn dann nicht mehr da
ist hat sie gesehen haben dass sie sich
da festgefahrener minister von einer
administration zur nächsten das kostet
die usa gemessen an ihrer
wirtschaftsleistung wirklich nicht
besonders viel gleichzeitig ist es so
dass sie dass sie russlands damit
schwächen bewusst an sich ja selbst
diese exponierte lage gebracht haben und
was meine amerikaner und nicht vergessen
hat es ist hier halt so die haben sich
jetzt hier dazu durchgerungen paket
panzer zu liefern da den amerikanern
sitzen die stärksten strategischen köpfe
da und überlegen sich wie können wir die
ukraine weiter unterstützen damit das
nicht so eskaliert dass die russen sagen
jetzt fängt ein großer krieger aber das
gleichzeitig den russen weh getan also
da kann man sich darauf verlassen glaube
ich danke herr pleitgen wir sind jetzt
am ende der sendung angekommen
tatsächlich und ich glaube das thema was
wir jetzt am ende auf gemacht haben wie
geht es in der ukraine weiter bank wird
es vielleicht eine kriegsmüdigkeit geben
das werden wir natürlich hier auch im
presseclub noch mal besprechen unser
thema heute war die nato nord
erweiterung und wir haben gesehen sie
wird wahrscheinlich kommen so die
einschätzung dieser runde hier ich
bedanke mich für ihr interesse es geht
weiter mit dem europamagazin wo es unter
anderem um bosnien herzegowina geht 30
jahre nach dem krieg und wenn sie auf
phoenix und wdr 5 dabei bleiben wollen
dann gibt es hier gleich presseclub
nachgefragt in jedem fall ihnen noch
einen guten sonntag und danke
[Musik]
und da sind wir wieder mit presseclub
nachgefragt bei phoenix und auf wdr5
unser thema weiterhin die nato nord
erweiterungen lebensversicherung gegen
putin die frage und ich möchte als
allererstes zu beate ergün nach aachen
schalten hallo und ihre frage bitte
frau ergrünen hören sie
ihre frage bitte hallo wir weckt also
wir der westen wir müssen aufpassen dass
das die zugeständnisse die erdogan
wieder von uns erpresst nicht regeln die
demokratischen werte geht es gibt in der
türkei kaum noch oder keine demokratie
mehr es gibt keine freie presse keine
unabhängige justiz
tausende politische häftlinge sind in
den gefängnissen erde da erdogan nutzt
diese erpressung wieder zum eigenen
machterhalt und gegen seine eigene
position und gegen die kurden frau
ergeben danke also die frage wie weit
kann man überhaupt in diesem
zusammenhang auf erdogan zu gehen frau
schneider wollen sie dafür genannt
wurden ich sehe das auch so also die
nato darf sich auf keinen fall
erpressbar machen wenn es um erdogan
geht
erdogan braucht die nato auch der kann
sich einen offenen bruch eigentlich gar
nicht leisten weil auch die wirtschaft
in der türkei wahnsinnig abhängig ist
vom westen und ein veto gegen finnland
und schweden wäre so ein bruch deswegen
denke ich dass man auch in brüssel und
washington das ganze ein bisschen
aushalten kann um zu schauen dass man ja
doch ein bisschen den wind aus den
segeln nimmt um dann auf den kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner zu kommen und das ist
wahrscheinlich eher vielleicht der
türkei usa gipfel der erde haben sich
wünscht und wo beiden im moment noch
sehr zögerlich ist oder vielleicht auch
die kampfflieger aber sicher nicht die
auslieferung von pkk anhängern soll wie
frau ärgern sagt es ist es gibt keine
keinen keine fairen prozess in der
türkei und so lange wird wahrscheinlich
auch kein europäisches land ausliefern
also eher auf diplomatischer ebene
erdogan entgegenkommen oder bei den
waffen ja sehr spannend wir gehen weiter
zu reinhard schneider nach düsseldorf
hallo und was möchten sie von der runde
sitzen ich bin hier der größte an die
runde
in der vergangenheit war es so dass die
meisten kriege dadurch begonnen wurden
weil es vorher zu einer fehleinschätzung
kam der ukraine konflikt ist so
kompliziert und nicht komisch nur
kompliziert er ist komplex
wenig hilfreich ist es wenn man zu
dieser komplexität vielleicht noch die
problematik der nato erweiterung von
schweden und finnland hinzu steigt das
klingt vielleicht ein teil des problems
werden aber nicht die die lösung des
konflikt wir haben immerhin es mit einer
macht zu tun der größten land
streitmacht das ist sind die sowjetunion
und eine atommacht und
meine frage ist eigentlich wie wir reden
über kriege so als wenn wir im
generalstab
für mich ist es wichtig wie sehen die
backups aus die eine unkontrollierte
eskalation des konfliktes verhindern und
wie sieht eine gesichtswahrende
win-win-situation aus die eine mögliche
wahnsinnstat nachvollziehbar verhindert
verstanden also sie schlagen den bogen
vom komplexen ukraine konflikt dass es
vielleicht jetzt nicht so gut ist auch
noch finnland und schweden aufzunehmen
und was man überhaupt tun kann um
möglicherweise ein nuklear schlag
russlands zu verhindern wer möchte
darauf also bitte also ich glaube das
ist eine ganz wichtige frage und ich
freue mich dass dir die gestellt haben
ich glaube dass das einst der der
größten probleme ist im moment um die
sich die nato sorgt die usa sich sorgen
ganz europa sich sorgt wie kann man zum
beispiel die ukraine im ganzen weiter
unterstützen ohne dass das ganze dann
ausartet in den krieg zwischen der nato
und russland der möglicherweise auch
nuklear werden das ist schon eine sache
die glaube ich ganz viele leute umtreibt
und ich glaube da ist auch der
militärhilfe an die ukraine der machen
sich auch ganz viele leute glaube ich
ganz große gedanken darum was kann man
den liefern damit die zum beispiel sich
selbst verteidigen können aber zum
beispiel keine großangriffe auf russland
starten können stichwort zum beispiel
kampfflugzeuge da hält man bislang sehr
zurück
langstreckenraketen zum beispiel für die
ukraine etwa erhält man bislang auf
zurück also ich glaube das verlangt
jetzt schon ziemlich viel
fingerspitzengefühl und ich glaube dass
die nato und und auch die usa als
führungsmacht der nato da schon auch
versuchen teilweise ein bisschen nicht
zu deeskalieren aber zumindest die seite
nicht weiter eskalieren zu lassen weil
wir können sich vielleicht daran
erinnern der putin hat ja am anfang von
konflikt gesagt es gibt jetzt ganz viel
rhetorik aus der nato wir setzen wir
jetzt unsere nuklear streitkräfte in
erhöhte alarmbereitschaft
und er hat der westen nicht auf reagiert
da an die usa nicht darauf reagiert also
ist jetzt schon besonnenes handeln
glaube ich extrem gefragt und
gleichzeitig ist es natürlich so dass
dass sich diese diese westlichen mächte
zu verschrieben haben der ukraine zu
helfen weil sie mein russland müsste
dort aufgehalten werden damit das ganze
dann nicht auf nato territorium
irgendwann weiter gebrochen wird danke
wir gehen weiter zu georg günther aus
eisenach in thüringen hallo und ihre
fragen bitte an schönen guten tag die
runde meine frage ist die post und auch
sicherheitsinteressen sowie das amerika
hat als kuba russischen raketen
stationiert worden sind wollte da eine
seeblockade von den amerikanern
vorgenommen weil ihre
sicherheitsinteressen gefährdet waren
nun ist aber bewusst und auch so den von
der nato und ekelt wären die das kochen
die keine regel interessen haben es
frage nach den russischen
sicherheitsinteressen
vielen dank für die frage hat russland
auch sicherheitsinteressen und
russland hat ja im vergangen jahr auch
forderungen an die nato gestellt und
auch an die usa auf der gleichzeitig hat
aber der kreml nicht erkennen lassen
dass man wirklich bereit wäre im dialog
darüber zu reden und diese fragen zu
lösen insofern ist die frage wie bereit
russland überhaupt wäre auf friedlichem
wege
kompromiss zu schaffen zum anderen
dieses argument dass häufig vom kreml
angebracht wird russland sei von der
nato um 10 geld stimmt einfach nicht
wenn man sich einfach nur anguckt wie
groß das land ist und wenn man sich das
auf der karte anguckt sieht man das gar
nicht möglich ist russland zu umzingeln
danke wir bleiben in thüringen und wir
gehen zu ulrich albrecht nach erfurt
frage
türkei braucht die türkei die nato bzw
ihre eigene nato mitgliedschaft gibt es
ernsthafte militärische bedrohung für
die türkei das ist das erste mal
wirklich ganz danach noch eine
hypothetische frage stellten okay zwei
fragen auf einmal das lassen wir
ausnahmsweise zu
braucht die türkei die
nato-mitgliedschaft herr schild
natürlich braucht
natürlich weil sie weil sie einfach
in einem extrem
instabilen umfeld
agiert und weil erdogan in den
vergangenen jahren auch sehr viel
porzellan zerschlagen hat gegenüber
einigen nachbarstaaten das versucht er
jetzt wieder zusammenzuflicken aber die
nato gewährt ihm ein höchstmaß an
sicherheit und garantiert ihnen dass
kein land dort im im nahen osten auf die
idee kommt die türkei anzugreifen
ernsthaft aber genauso braucht die
türkei braucht die nato auch die türkei
das dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen ja
deswegen muss man auch die
diese fraktion die im moment herrschen
ernst nehmen seitens der nato oder über
das ist kein land wie
luxemburg oder montenegro die türkei ja
also jetzt genau jetzt ihr follow up
herr albrecht die hypothetische frage
die begeistern gewaltige militärmacht
wahrscheinlich eine der größten ist
führend beim thronen mehr wird der titel
kann greift das letztlich keinen zusatz
phase nur ein statement aus dieser
geschichte leidig wirklich diese über
den fahrer ableiten jetzt könnte herr
tuan vielleicht wir können nicht in
seinen kopf oben auf die idee kommen
praktisch die nato mitgliedschaft von
finnland und schweden platzen zu lassen
unpraktisch
dies auf dieser grundlage mit putin ins
geschäft zu kommen und sozusagen putin
an den verhandlungstisch zu bringen sagt
wenn ich das durchhalte gehe an einer
ernsthaften verhandlungen rein und
versteht er könnte dann und als großer
friedensbringer dastehen wollte aber die
nato-mitgliedschaft riskieren wie gesagt
dass das was darauf dass ich das ich
annehme im gegensatz dass die türkei den
also nicht so stark braucht wie
umgekehrt das ist doch ein unterschied
könnte könnte das als verhandlungsmasse
in die waagschale geworfen werden von
türkischer seite ist der herr albrecht
das geht so ein bisschen zu schließt
anderen das was frau schneider schon
gesagt hat dass sie darin ja auch ein
erstes signal sehen dass erdogan hier
vielleicht die brücken zu russland
aufrechterhalten will mit dieser veto
androhung glauben sie dass das am ende
hypothetisch dabei rauskommen können
also bei ja dann ist vieles möglich das
halte ich für sehr unwahrscheinlich dass
er die nato mitgliedschaft von vier
schweden und finnland jetzt platzen ist
und um mit putin zu reden also der
offene bruch mit der nato wäre für
erdogan ein großes wagnis wirtschaftlich
und auch
sicherheitspolitisch wie gesagt in der
region
herrscht große instabilität ich halte
das nicht für wahrscheinlich dass das
waren entgegen in dem fall ist
danke dann gehen wir mal in den hohen
norden zu klaus borchert in börnsen
schleswig holstein bei hamburg hallo
ihren frage bitte
ja
ich werde den kopf gehen zum einen ist
er überhaupt nicht egal wie russland
jetzt militärische vorgeht welchen
vorteil russland als land auf diesem
ganzen ereignissen überhaupt sehen will
der muss gebrandmarkt das müsste sich
auch langsam mit russland oben sprechen
und zum anderen denke hier erdogan wird
irgendwas eine ss 400 raketen in die
ukraine liefern und die konsequent und
gut gebrauchen und kriegt dafür erwerb
auf amerika und die pkk ist in den
meisten ländern europas ich schon
verboten was spricht dagegen für ihren
film land und schweden auch zu verbieten
ok also verstehe sie haben jetzt
verschiedene fragen aufgeworfen dass das
raketenabwehrsystem was sie gerade
genannt haben ist das russische was die
türkei bezogen hat und wo sie sagen
vielleicht liefert das die türkei jetzt
einfach an die ukraine und gleichzeitig
verbieten wir die pkk dann noch in
dass sie durch die versehentliche
slowenien die ihre s 300 an die ukraine
geliefert und dafür patriot die slowakei
für hand und die dann patriot
abwehrraketen dafür gekriegt haben also
ein präsident zwar gibt es dafür ob der
erde und dazu bereit ist
ist unklar
ich muss gestehen den gedanken hatte ich
auch schon mal hast du das glück in der
sache wäre wenn er dadurch zum beispiel
die patriot-raketen kriegen könnte und
dann auch wieder 1 f 35 programm
aufgenommen werden würde weil er dann
die sp 100 nicht mehr hat das ist so ein
gedankenspiel ich weiß nicht ob das
irgendwo diskutiert wird aber das wird
ja das wird das tier habe ich weiß dass
ich finde das schon ganz ganz
interessantes gesagt ob das netzwerk
auch realistischer weise glauben dass
das realistisch interactions nicht
einfach ich glaube in diesem fall
tatsächlich wäre das eine große
provokation wenn das s400 system dann
seinen weg zurück in die oder in der
ukraine findet ich glaube dass genau
also das russische pendant franck sich
schon ab wer sich genauer werden das von
erdogan jetzt der ukraine gegeben würde
das wäre eigentlich eine maximale
provokationen die amerikaner das
vermutlich auch nicht zulassen aber ich
konnte also wer zumindest schwierig aber
ob das komplett ausgeschlossen ich meine
die s-300 ist ja ein silberschatz
starkes system die s-300 erster ehrung
hatte der vorgänger von der s400 das ist
auch eine rakete die chinesen das ist
einfach das ist ein flugabwehrsystem das
funktioniert quasi mit einem radar das
radar scannt den luftraum und dass er da
sieht ein flugzeug und das leitet dann
mit einem anderen rad dem feuerleiter da
eine rakete in das flugzeug rein für die
nähe von flugzeug explodiert und dieses
s-300 ist darüber gemacht dass ein sehr
großer höhe also keine haben wir von
unseren anderen ländern paar mit sohn
und meine schulter schießt sie keine
tiefflieger abschießen und die anderen
können hat höher fliegen und diese s-300
die hat sich sehr als sehr effektiv
herausgestellt für die ukraine ich
versuche eine frage noch vielen dank für
diesen militärischen exkurs an der
stelle da war ich jetzt auch nicht so
ganz
informations sicher wir gehen noch zu
karl heinz zahn nach leipzig halle und
was möchten sie gerne noch fragen
gehen die runde schaffen ganz kurze
frage oder antwort dazu auch und zwar
geht das wort raum in finnland und
schweden dann dazu beiträgen beitreten
kann das eigentlich aus dem lotto und
toto dauth seien aber aus einem ganz
anderen grund weiß endlich mal etwas
mehr realismus in die gesamte geschichte
eingeht ob läuft ich kann mich noch sehr
gut erinnern als ihn später
auftauchten wo allem eines werfen
russische reporter was natürlich stand
als fehler erwiesen hat danke ok also
sie sagen dieses beispiel weiß nicht
kann dass vielleicht jemand einordnen
und es geht darum kehrt mehr realismus
in die nato ein mit diesen 29
mitgliedern herr schild ich glaube es
mehr realismus die nato ist sehr
realistisch finde ich auch eine sehr
erfolgreiche allianz in den letzten
jahren sie ist jetzt revitalisiert
worden auch ein effekt dieses krieges
aber die nato wird in jedem fall stärker
realistisch war sie schon und jetzt wird
sie deutlich stärker vor allem das hat
die kolleginnen eben auch erwähnt sie
ist deutlich stärker in der lage das
baltikum zu sichern und die urangst der
balken war abgeschnitten zu werden vom
westen bei den transporten und bei der
versorgung im falle eines krieges und
diese urangst wird ihm jetzt genommen
weil die ostsee ist weitgehend von der
nato kontrolliert und sie können vor
allem von der insel gotland dann die
versorgung des baltikums machen und das
ist ein so immenser vorteil für die nato
dem wir glaube ich gar nicht im moment
schon um reißen können
als kurzes hinzufügen die nato
profitierte natürlich auch von den
geheimdienstlichen informationen aus
schweden und finnland beide länder haben
extrem viel wissen über russland und das
macht die nato vielleicht nicht
realistischer wie gesagt sie ist bereits
realistisch aber stärker in der
einschätzung und mit noch mehr expertise
ausgestattet militärisch und von der
geheimdiensterkenntnisse ja vielen dank
für ihre fragen auch für die
einschätzung aus der runde das war
presseclub nachgefragt auf phoenix und
wdr 5 ich hoffe dass wir sie aufschlagen
könnten beim thema nato nord
erweiterungen und wünsche ihnen noch
einen guten sonntag danke und tschüss
[Musik]